[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien schönen guten Abend die
sportlichen Neuigkeiten später wieder
mit Katja Stresow
und das haben wir heute unter anderem
für Sie vorbereitet
es brodelt über Deutschland heftige
Gewitter haben erste Schäden angerichtet
in der Nacht droht mehr
neue Streiks bei der Bahn die
Gewerkschaft DVG will in einer
Urabstimmung über unbefristete Streiks
entscheiden
psychisch krank durch den Job erstmals
erkennt das Bundessozialgericht die
Folgen von Traumata bei einem
Rettungssanitäter als Berufskrankheit an
[Musik]
ein Tief namens Lambert beschert uns
seine sogenannte schwergewitterlage
nachdem es Frankreich schon traf ist das
Unwetter weiter zu uns gezogen der
Deutsche Wetterdienst war bis in die
Nacht vor Starkregen Hochwasser
vereinzelt sein Tornados möglich wir
schauen uns das ganze mal auf dem
wolkenfilm an los ging es da schon am
Vormittag als ein großes wolkengebiet
mit Gewitter und Starkregen von
Nordrhein-Westfalen weiterzog im Laufe
des Tages trafen weitere Gewitter vor
allem Niedersachsen Hessen und
Baden-Württemberg über die unwetterlage
und Schäden jetzt Christian Volk
bis zu 5 cm groß sind die Hagelkörner
die hier am Nachmittag bei Kassel
runterkommen eine sogenannte Superzelle
sorgt für Land unter sie bringt extremen
Wind und Regen mit beschädigt Autodächer
seit 16:30 Uhr kommen Polizei und
Feuerwehr in der Stadt nicht mehr
hinterher zu viele Anrufe zu viele
Einsätze mehr als 100 sind es innerhalb
kürzester Zeit in der gesamten Region
laufen Keller voll Autos stehen unter
Wasser die Einsatzkräfte schaffen es
nicht mehr alle Fälle zu dokumentieren
das gesamte Ausmaß der Schäden deshalb
noch unklar und auch in Rheinland-Pfalz
Starkregen und schwere Orkanböen die
Hitze der vergangenen Tage entlädt sich
innerhalb weniger Minuten mehrere Bäume
stürzen auf eine Fahrbahn im Kreis
Cochem Zell einer landet auf einem
Lastwagen verletzt wurde dabei niemand
bei Göttingen zeigt sich welches
Naturschauspiel hinter den extremen
Unwettern steckt in den kommenden
Stunden ziehen die weiter in den Osten
Deutschlands
ja erste heftige Bilder unser
Meteorologe östant Herrli ist jetzt im
Studio östion hallo wo stehen wir
aktuell und was Kommt da noch auf uns zu
er diese heftigen Gewitter diesen
hauptsächlich noch im Westen und dehnen
sich langsam Richtung Norden aus ich
habe eben gesehen die wachsen nun
allmählich auch im Süden Deutschlands
weiter an und wir müssen weiterhin mit
Hagel sturmteils orkanböden und großen
Regenmengen rechnen das ist also noch
nicht vorbei es wird über Nacht andauern
und es ist weiterhin auch gefährlich vor
allen Dingen den Osten muss man da
wahrscheinlich auch noch im Blick haben
was bedeutet das denn jetzt für all jene
die dann mit Gewitter rechnen bzw damit
konfrontiert sind ja wir haben es ja
gerade in den Bildern gesehen also wenn
tatsächlich so viel Wasser runterkommt
und dann die Keller volllaufen natürlich
nicht in den Keller gehen um irgendwas
noch rauszuholen das ist natürlich
lebensgefährlich aber auch mit den Autos
nicht durchs Wasser fahren vor allem
wenn es ein fließendes Gewässer ist das
heißt dann einfach das Auto mit dann
vielen Dank ist denn für all diese
Informationen wir halten sie natürlich
weiter auf dem Lauf enden wie es mit den
Unwettern an diesem Abend und in der
Nacht weitergeht erfahren Sie aktuell
jederzeit online in unserer ZDF heute
App
so nicht nur für Nordrhein-Westfalen wo
heute die Sommerferien beginnen kommt
die Nachricht zu uns Zeit die
Tarifgespräche zwischen Bahn und EVG
sind gescheitert die
Gewerkschaftsmitglieder sollen jetzt in
einer Uhr Abstimmung überstreiks
entscheiden und so könnte diese
Urlaubssaison für Millionen zur
Zitterpartie werden Stefan berichtet
wollen die Züge in den Sommerferien oder
nicht Ende Februar haben die
Verhandlungen zwischen Bahn und EVG
begonnen jetzt hat die Gewerkschaft sie
für gescheitert erklärt organisiert nun
die Urabstimmung zum Streik
es kann vier bis fünf Wochen in Anspruch
nehmen je nachdem
es läuft aber alles jetzt an sind auch
wandstreiks weiterhin nicht
ausgeschlossen die Bahn kritisiert die
Pläne der EVG scharf und hält
schriftlich mit diese Eskalation ist
absolut unnötig wir waren ganz kurz vor
dem Abschluss ein Ergebnis wird durch
die Urabstimmung und Monate verzögert es
lag vor allem am Geld laut EVG wollte
die Bahn das Gehalt erst ab Dezember
erhöhen das war der Gewerkschaft zu spät
und insgesamt auch zu wenig für die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
weiterer Knackpunkt die Laufzeit des
Vertrages die Bahn bot 27 Monate die EVG
wollte zwölf für die Reisenden Drohnen
im Sommer Streik und Stress
ich kann es auf der einen Seite
verstehen als Bankkunde finde ich es
natürlich
ätzend wenn Züge ausfallen ja ich finde
es unmöglich das ist wie wohnen essen
und so ist Mobilität einfach auch
wichtig das wird alles teurer und die
wollen halt auch ihren Teil mehr
verdienen und insofern Geist zum Teil
schon nachvollziehen mal anstreckt wären
jederzeit möglich sagt die Gewerkschaft
sie wolle aber rechtzeitig informieren
was rechtzeitig ist sagt die EVG heute
nicht
weniger Bürokratie und mehr
Investitionen das brauche der Osten
fordert der sächsische
CDU-Ministerpräsident Kretschmer in
Chemnitz trafen sich heute die
Ostdeutschen Länderchefs mit dabei war
auch Bundeskanzler Scholz wichtiges
Thema die Wirtschaft bei der regionalen
Förderung dürfen es nicht zu den
geplanten Kürzungen kommen verlangten
die Ministerpräsidenten denn die Stützen
Handwerk und kleine Betriebe die im
Osten prägend sind
ein wichtiges Urteil kommt heute vom
Bundessozialgericht es hat heute zum
ersten Mal eine psychische Erkrankung
als Berufskrankheit anerkannt konkret
ging es um einen Rettungssanitäter der
an einer posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörung leidet er war mehrmals
im Einsatz dramatischen Ereignissen
ausgesetzt und dann erkrankt die
Unfallkasse weigerte sich bislang zu
zahlen Christoph Schneider dazu
Rettungssanitäter haben einen schweren
Job als Erster am Unfallort mit schweren
Verletzungen konfrontiert so auch Uwe t
der unerkannt bleiben möchte er war beim
Amoklauf von Winnenden 2009 im Einsatz
hat später eine jugendliche erlebt die
durch selbst Enthauptung Suizid beginnt
viele tausend Einsätze in 27
Dienstjahren die haben ihn mitgenommen
am Anfang als junger Kerle der lebst du
viel da steckt es einfach weg und dann
kann ich das sogar sagen wie dass es dir
irgendwann mal vielleicht später
in die Kniekehlen geht oder so und dich
praktisch zu Boden hämmert die leidet
unter einer posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörung kurz PTBS doch die war
überhaupt wie jegliche psychische
Erkrankung nicht als Berufskrankheit
anerkannt anerkannt sind dagegen
Hörschäden bei Bauarbeiter nur der
Knieschäden bei Fliesenlegern aber ein
schwertraumatisierter Rettungssanitäter
gehörte bisher nicht dazu bis jetzt denn
das Bundessozialgericht entscheidet PTBS
kann als Berufskrankheit anerkannt
werden
neue wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse
belegen das Rettungssanitäter in höherem
Maß als die Gesamtbevölkerung dem Risiko
ausgesetzt sind an einer
posttraumatischen Belastungsstörung zu
erkranken konkret heißt das dass in
Fällen der PTBS die gesetzliche
Unfallversicherung finanzielle Schäden
ausgleichen muss ein Urteil mit
Signalwirkung über den Fall hinaus zum
allerersten Mal ist eine psychische
Erkrankung als Berufskrankheit anerkannt
worden das hat es vorher nicht gegeben
das macht einen wahnsinniges Tor auf für
alle Betroffenen
das ist ein riesiges Signal an all
diejenigen die im Rettungsdienst tätig
sind Uwe tief Klage allerdings über die
muss noch mal das Landes Sozialgericht
Baden-Württemberg entscheiden weil noch
juristische Details zu klären sind doch
seine Chancen für eine am Ende
erfolgreiche Klage sie sind gut
der Bundestag hat eine Reform des
Strafrechts beschlossen die
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe werden die
ersatzfreiheit Strafen Entschuldigung
werden reduziert sie werden fällig wenn
eine Geldstrafe nicht bezahlt wird oder
bezahlt werden kann künftig gibt es für
zwei Tagessätze Geldstrafe nur noch
einen Tag Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
die neue LNG-Anlage in Wilhelmshaven
kann wie geplant den nächsten zwei
Jahrzehnte fossiles Erdgas über
Pipelines verteilen das hat das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht entschieden und
eine Klage der Deutschen Umwelthilfe
abgelehnt die Umweltschützer wollten
erreichen dass die Durchleitung von
fossilem Gas befristet wird bis 2033
danach sollte die Pipeline aus
Klimaschutzgründen für den Transport von
grünem Wasserstoff genutzt werden
in dieser Phase des Krieges sprechen
sowohl die Ukraine als auch Russland von
hohen Verlusten beim Gegner und wie so
vieles lässt sich das nicht unabhängig
überprüfen ein russischer Sprecher
bestätigte dass eine wichtige Brücke
zwischen der Halbinsel Krim und der
südukrainischen Region herson durch
einen ukrainischen Angriff beschädigt
wurde und damit beginnt der Bericht von
Volker duscheck
Tor zur Krim nennen die Ukraine und
Militärs die John harbrücke seit 55 hat
das Tor zur Krim große Löcher sowohl die
Hauptbrücke als auch die stillgelegte
alte Brücke daneben verletzt wird
offenbar niemand für die Russen ist es
der wichtigste Korridor um die eigenen
Truppen in der Region mit Nachschub zu
versorgen die Brücke verbindet die
bereits 2014 von Russland annektierte
Halbinsel Krim mit dem Festland mit der
Region das Angriffsziel liegt 100 km
hinter der Front ein Signal offenbar an
Moskau es soll sagen fühlt euch nicht zu
sicher um die Gebiete im Süden und um
die Versorgung dieser Truppen und der
russischen Seite im Süden und das war
sehr wirkungsvoller Schlag und ist auch
eine psychologische Wirkung wenn die
Russen wissen diese Brücke befindet sich
in Reichweite der Langstreckenwaffen der
Ukraine
viele Experten sind sich einig die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive wird durch
stark vermietes Gebiet und
Raketenangriffe verlangsamt
Opfer ist zumeist die Zivilbevölkerung
Menschen wie Natascha und Alexandre in
pokrowski in der Region dornierts gerade
wurde ihr Haus getroffen dann klingelt
das Telefon
ja Mutter es hat unser Haus getroffen
ich wurde verwundet
an der beschädigten Brücke zur Krim
präsentieren die ukrainischen
Statthalter moskauz trümmerreste sie
sollen beweisen dass auch Raketen
französischer Bauart verwendet wurden
morgens war noch die Rede von einem
britischen Marschflugkörper auch der
Wahrheitsgehalt dieser Aussagen lässt
sich nicht überprüfen
seit vielen Jahren gibt es Spannungen
zwischen dem Kosovo und Serbien Serbien
erkennt die Souveränität des
Nachbarlandes nicht an im Norden des
Kosovo Leben mehrheitlich sehr sie
fordern mehr Autonomie und wie die
aussehen könnte darüber gibt es seit
Jahrzehnten nicht seit Jahrzehnten seit
Jahren Streit zuletzt entludden sich die
Spannungen wieder in Gewalt und heute
versucht die EU zwischen beiden Seiten
zu vermitteln Wolf Christian Ulrich
berichtet wenn der 17-jährige Marco
morgens in Nord Mitrovica die Sportbar
für die Gäste vorbereitet fühlte sich
nicht als wäre er hier in Kosovo
für mich ist das hier Serbien aber
entscheidend sind wir besetzt weil meine
Armee nicht hier ist meine Polizei nicht
und weil mein Volk hier terrorisiert
wird
so klingt es wenn serbische
Regierungspropaganda Früchte trägt
überall hängen hier serbische Fahnen die
Schulen und Krankenhäuser sind serbisch
verwaltet in diesem Lädchen bezahlt man
mit serbischen Dinar und nicht mit Euro
wie sonst in Kosovo wie autonom sind die
Serbien Kosovo das Streit Thema seit
Jahren
egal welcher Seite dieser Konflikt
bringt keinem etwas meint dieser Server
doch der Kampf um die Hoheit im Land
wird hart geführt als Kosovos Regierung
albanische Bürgermeister ins anbringen
ließ obwohl die Serben die Wahl
boykottiert hatten kam es zu Gewalt nun
müssen k-vorsoldaten Bürgermeister
unterstützen die USA und auch die EU
entzogen Kosovo Unterstützung die
Regierung von Ministerpräsident Kurti
wehrt sich sagt die Gewalt sei zum Teil
von Belgrad ausgesteuert es hilft nicht
wenn wir dauernd nach Brüssel gehen
irgendwelche Dinge Zusagen die uns über
irgendwelche Dinge einigen und am Ende
geht Herr Vucic und provoziert Gewalt im
Norden geht gegen Nato-Soldaten vor ich
rede nicht mit Kurti sagt dagegen
Serbiens Präsident Vucic bevor er nach
Brüssel fährt mit ihm zu reden ergibt
keinen Sinn noch nicht mal ein
Gruppenbild am Abend in Brüssel der
eu-fehler eine schlichtungsstrategie
sagen Experten für die Serben im Norden
von Kosovo lautet der Slogan bis auf
weiteres dies ist Serbien
interessante Zahlen kommt vom
Statistischen Bundesamt immer mehr
Menschen leben in Deutschland alleine in
41% der gut 40 Millionen Haushalte lebt
nur eine Person das sind die neuesten
Daten 1950 waren es nur 19% von den
heute allein lebenden sind gut die
Hälfte ledig 25% verwitwettet und 19%
geschieden
in Paris geht es auf einem
internationalen Gipfel um die Folgen des
Klimawandels das Ziel mehr Geld für den
Klimaschutz in
ärmeren Ländern viele benötigen da ja
dringend Hilfe jetzt ist er ein
solidarisches Finanzsystem im Gespräch
Details sind allerdings noch nicht
geklärt gastgeber Frankreich sucht mit
hochrangigen Gästen nach einer Lösung
Thomas Walde
Frankreichs Präsident macron empfängt
UNO generalsekretärisch Regierungschefs
und Vertreter internationaler
Finanzorganisationen macron will alle
antreiben zu ambitionierteren
Klimaschutz und seiner Finanzierung
sein zwischen der Reduktion von Armut
und dem Schutz des Planeten wählen zu
müssen angesichts der doppelten
Herausforderung von Armut und
Biodiversität brauchen wir viel mehr
Investitionen
die Vereinten Nationen schätzen dass der
globale südengrund zwei Billionen Euro
bräuchte um sich gegen die Klimakrise zu
wappnen doch viele Länder sind
überschuldeten haben weitere Probleme
armut kann man nicht von Klima trennen
Bildung und Klima kann man nicht trennen
eine kleine Kerner bis separated der
Internationale Währungsfonds soll
reformiert Klimaschutz beim
Schuldenabbau angerechnet und
Privatkapital mobilisiert werden
Vertreter des Südens sehen die Industrie
Länder in der Pflicht
wir brauchen Schuldenreduzierung und
Erlass denn bei der Zerstörung des
Planeten schuldet nicht der Süden dem
Norden etwas sondern der Norden ist
verantwortlich dass wir uns in einer
Klimakrise befinden und Geld leihen
müssen um damit fertig zu werden das
Treffen in Paris soll Aufmerksamkeit
schaffen ein Forum für verbindliche
Beschlüsse ist es nicht es markiert
damit bestenfalls einen Zwischenschritt
zu einer gerechteren Finanzierung des
Klimaschutzes
bei der Suche nach dem vermissten im
Nordatlantik ist nahe des Titanic Wracks
ein Trümmerfeld entdeckt worden das
meldet die US-Küstenwache vor etwa einer
Stunde
Suchteams hatten sofort versucht das
Boot mit fünf Menschen an Bord zu orten
dabei helfen auch Tiefsee Roboter die
Titan war am Sonntag zu ihrer Tauchfahrt
aufgebrochen kurz danach brach der
Kontakt ab
Johannes Hano beobachtet die Suche von
New York aus johannes ist jetzt also mit
einem tragischen Ausgang zu rechnen
also erstmal muss man sagen das war ein
kanadisches Spezialschiff das mit einem
Tauchroboter darunter getaucht ist und
dieses Trümmerfeld entdeckt hat und
offiziell heißt es man wissen noch nicht
genau was wird Trümmer es sich handelt
aber dass die Küstenwache diese
Information jetzt so vor einer Stunde
veröffentlicht hat lässt viele vermuten
dass sie küssenmacher selbst nicht mehr
davon ausgeht die Besatzung der Titan
noch Leben zu retten wir werden in
ungefähr zwei Stunden an der
Pressekonferenz haben die Küstenwache
wird dann dort erzählen wie die
Situation ist fest steht man hat über
Nacht einen weiteren Spezial
Tauchroboter aus Großbritannien
einfliegen lassen und dieser
Tauchroboter wird eingesetzt er kann
hochauflösende Fotos machen und er hat
greifarbe man erhofft sich also
vielleicht diese Trümmerteile die man
dort entdeckt hat zugreifen und
vielleicht dann auch mit den eigenen
Augen sowieso hell zu bestätigen und was
sie sich da handelt aber ich glaube er
muss davon ausgehen dass aus der
Rettungsaktion die es bislang war eine
Bergungsaktion wird denn der Sauerstoff
den die Titan an Bord hatte der schon
heute morgen ausgegangen und ich glaube
es gibt nicht mehr besonders viel
Hoffnung die Menschen der Zeit an die
Besatzung der Zeit daneben zu retten
live Informationen aus New York vielen
Dank Johannes Hano
im Nordwesten China sind bei einer
Gasexplosion in einem Restaurant
mindestens 31 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen mehrere Menschen wurden zum
Teil schwer verletzt Mitarbeiter
berichteten sie hätten eine Stunde vor
der Explosion bereits Gasgeruch bemerkt
dennoch sei nicht evakuiert worden die
Polizei nahm neun Menschen fest unter
ihnen auch den Restaurantbesitzer
wir sind jetzt beim Sport Katja und du
beginnst mit Frauenfußball ja die DFB
Frauen haben Quartier bezogen in
Herzogenaurach dort wollen sie sich den
letzten Schliff holen für die Fußball-WM
in Australien und Neuseeland die heute
in vier Wochen beginnt
die heiße Phase beginnt der WM Countdown
läuft doch die Vorbereitung war bislang
kein glatter Durchmarsch das Testspiel
gegen Brasilien war ein Knackpunkt 1:2
verloren am Samstag will das deutsche
Team im Spiel gegen Vietnam testen
feilen gewinnen als Mannschaft zusammen
zu wachsen ein Team zu werden
es ist natürlich wieder extrem wichtig
und die Kapitänin macht ihr WM Ziel klar
ja ich möchte den Titel holen
klar der Konkurrenzkampf um die 23
kaderplätze für die WM ist groß
zum Tennis Deutschlands aktuelle Nummer
eins Jan Lennart stroph hat es nicht
unter die Top 8 das ATP Turniers in
Halle Westfalen geschafft er verlor am
Achtelfinale gegen den Kasachen
Alexander bublik mit drei zu sechs
sieben zu sechs und drei zu sechs und
auch für Jule Niemeyer kam das Aus im
Achtelfinale in dem Fall beim WTA
Turnier in Berlin Niemeyer war im
zweiten Satz gegen die Tschechien von
Bruce war aufs Handgelenk gefallen
spielte noch unter Schmerzen weiter gab
dann aber beim Stand von drei zu sechs
und fünf zu sechs schließlich auf
ja es gibt aber auch positive Meldungen
aus Berlin denn für die deutschen Judoka
war bei den Special Olympics ein
fünffacher gold-tag besonders schön für
ein Liebespaar aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
doppeltes Gold gleich doppeltes Glück
die Judoka Andrea Kuhne und Timo Kammer
haben sich beim Training kennengelernt
und nun gewinnen beide am gleichen Tag
Gold
drei Kämpfe drei Siege so wie ihr Freund
gewinnt auch Andrea Kunis souverän ihren
Wettbewerb dank der goldkrämer Stiftung
konnten beide sich wie Profis auf diese
Spiele vorbereiten das war
unbeschreiblich das Gefühl und ich bin
mega stolz und das nächste Highlight
steht bald an bereits vor dem Special
Olympics hat Timo Andrea einen
Heiratsantrag gemacht
es menschelt danke Katja ja wieder sind
wir beim Wetter vor allem Richtung Osten
droht noch großes unwetterpotenzial
ostentelli bringt uns gleich auf den
neuesten Stand mehr zur aktuellen
unwetterlage auch ab 21:45 Uhr bei
Christian Sievers im heute-journal
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und noch ein
entspannten Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die gefährliche
unwetterlage hält noch weiterhin an denn
wir haben es immer noch mit dem
gewittertief lamber zu tun das zieht
allmählich über uns hinweg nach Osten
dahinter lockert es auf morgen im
Tagesverlauf in der Nacht gibt es
weiterhin heftige Gewitter nach Norden
hin und die bringen stark Regen 30 bis
60 Liter auf dem Quadratmeter
örtlich sogar um die 100 Liter nach
Süden ebenfalls heftige Gewitter teils
mit Hagel und Orkanböen das steht uns
noch bevor in dieser Nacht Temperaturen
gehen zurück auf 20 Grad im Osten
Deutschlands und 13 Grad im hessischen
Bergland und morgen am Vormittag gibt es
schauen Gewitter in der Osthälfte des
verlagert sich auch ostwärts ansonsten
aber durchaus sonniger Abschnitte von
Westen her bei höchsten Temperaturen von
28 Grad im Rhein-Main-Gebiet und 19 Grad
Richtung Ostsee am Wochenende wird es
deutlich ruhiger aber auch wieder heißer
mit viel Sonnenschein und am Montag
kommen neue Schauer und Gewitter auf
damit ein schöner Abend